este lunes la británica astrazéneca
anunció que las pruebas de última fase
mostraron que su vacuna contra el
coronavirus está teniendo una tasa de
eficacia importante porque cuando
miramos los datos un poco más allá en
los dos diferentes regímenes de
dosificación que usamos uno de los
regímenes de dosificación tiene un 90%
de eficacia y el otro tiene un 62% de
eficacia y el régimen de mayor eficacia
es mejor tolerados en el hecho de que
régimen de media dosis seguido de una
dosis completa sea el más efectivo es
una buena noticia porque significa que
más personas pueden ser vacunadas
desarrollada con contribuciones de
méxico y argentina
la vacuna tendrá un alcance mayor en
latinoamérica donde también fue objeto
de pruebas en brasil la china de sinovac
de fase 3 a través de un convenio con el
instituto butantán de sao paulo también
podría llegar a latinoamérica la russa
sputnik 5 con tasa de eficacia el 92% se
está probando en la región en venezuela
la vacuna estadounidense de johnson
johnson está actualmente en fase de
prueba
brasil chile colombia méxico y perú
finalmente la única candidata en
latinoamericana autorizada por la oms es
la cubana soberana que se encuentra en
la fase 3 y que presenta altas tasas de
eficacia según anuncia el gobierno de la
isla a diferencia de otras vacunas la
candidata astrazéneca no tiene que ser
almacenada a temperaturas ultra frías lo
que facilita su distribución
especialmente en países en vías de
desarrollo por otra parte el laboratorio
también informó que durante el periodo
de la pandemia no se hará ningún
beneficio una manera de mantener bajo el
precio de la vacuna de la cual prevén
200 millones de dosis disponibles antes
del final del año